c'était donc le festival d'avignon si
proche si loin on attend bien sûr vos
réactions sur le hashtag d'aucune débat
pierre bond joseph bonjour vous avez
réalisé ce documentaire merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés jean-michel djian
bonjour vous êtes journaliste rédacteur
en chef de la revue france culture
papier hauteur de politique culturelle
la fin d'un mythe bienvenus près de vous
thierry maignan bonjour vous êtes maire
les républicains du blanc-mesnil
conseiller départemental de seine saint
denis
en face de vous bernard faivre d'arcier
bonjour jai ancien directeur du festival
d'avignon président de la biennale de
lyon et enfin catherine tasca bienvenue
vous avez été ministre de la culture de
2000 à 2002 est aujourd'hui sénatrice ps
des yvelines
bienvenue à vous alors pierre bank
joseph comment est né ce documentaire il
aidé d'un contexte politique local
surprenant on est en mars 2014 de front
national est aux portes du pouvoir le
candidat frontiste fait 30% des voix au
premier tour et à ce moment là le tout
nouveau directeur du festival d'avignon
qui est olivier py menace de quitter la
ville en disant que pour lui il ya une
incompatibilité si le front national
devenait venez à gérer la ville
voilà donc ce contexte là j'ai voulu
l'interroger comment se fait-il que dans
une ville symbole de culte est un
symbole d'émancipation symbole de deux
d'ouverture aussi eh bien on avait une
population qui faisait presque le choix
d'avoir un maire frontiste c'est ce
paradoxe que j'ai voulu interroger et
donc naturellement je me suis posé la
question est bien de relations qu'il
pouvait y avoir entre ce festival
premier festival de théâtre du monde où
quasiment enfin avec edimbourg
commandant celui là qui aux yeux de tous
était un lieu de culture et de théâtre
et bien le les avignonnais ne faisait ce
choix diamétralement opposées ce pont
pour vous il y avait forcément un lien a
montré entre un festival de théâtre le
plus grand festival de théâtre du monde
et une la 14e ville la plus pauvre de
france avec sa jeunesse frappée par 25 %
de chômage et ses quartiers fragiles on
sent que vous voulez créer un lien entre
ces deux phénomènes
qu'est ce que en fait vous vouliez
montrer exactement alors qu'est ce que
la culture ranger pour vous est
forcément synonyme de lien social
alors le lien c'est le lieu 1 c'est ce
même territoire
aujourd'hui quand on regardait vignon il
ya de l'hyper centre les remparts le le
palais des papes les remparts qui
enferme set gilles et puis le reste de
la ville des quartiers comme champ
fleuri la rocade où vivent cet
avignonnais sur dix il ya mais comme
dans beaucoup de villes cette séparation
entre le centre et puis la périphérie où
se retrouvent les poches de pauvreté
les peaux les poches de pauvreté des
poches de délinquance vous lisiez 14e
ville la plus vide et criminogène de
france rapporté à sa population un et le
festival d'avignon qui arrive un mois
par an et le festival en tout cas c'est
ce que je voulais interroger au lieu de
s'adresser à l'ensemble est bien se
glisse finalement dans ses remparts dans
cette hyper centre et ne va que très peu
à la rencontre des habitants
j'aimerais vos réactions à ce
documentaire catherine tasca
est ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
les intentions du réalisateur est ce que
votre regard différent ce qu'il a eu
tout à fait raison de de saisir cette
conjoncture pour s'interroger sur la
place réelle du festival dans la ville
d'avignon
ceci étant je pense que ce serait une
erreur d'imputer au festival cette cette
coupure dont on parle entre le centre
ville et ses quartiers excentrés tout ça
résulte d'une situation sociale
économique qui est fort complexe et qui
évidemment n'est pas lié en tout cas pas
uniquement à la politique culturelle qui
est qui est menée là
la coupure nous interpelle il faut y
travailler d'ailleurs le documentaire
montre un certain nombre de tentatives
de théâtre amateur associant vraiment
les les citoyens de ces quartiers
ce qui manque peut-être dans le
documentaire c'est l'apport spécifique
du du festival in on sent très bien le
bouillonnement du festival off c'est à
dire tout ce qui se passe dans des tours
très grand nombre de lieux
y compris d'ailleurs dans le centre
ville mais dans des lieux qui se sont
démultipliés est la question que moi je
me pose c'est est-ce que cette abondance
de d'activités théâtrales dans ce temps
très très court aurait pu exister sans
l'existence du festival in
quant à la question du lien social elle
est évidemment très très importante pour
toute politique culturelle mais elle ne
peut pas se substituer à l'aventuré
artistique non plus on a raison de
s'interroger sur le lien social qui peut
se bâtir autour des spectacles autour
des prestations artistiques
mais ce lien social n'est pas l'unique
objet ou l'unique but de l'activité d'un
festival comme celui d'avignon bien à
favre d'ars et oui alors il y a mal
entendu à penser que le festival
d'avignon doit avoir une sorte d'
influence sur la situation culturelle de
l'ensemble de la population avignonnaise
parce que en fait ce n'est pas le rôle
du festival d'avignon et cela n'a jamais
été
jean vilar n'était pas chargée de
l'action culturelle dans la ville
d'avignon
d'ailleurs il est un peu découvert à
avignon avant finalement d'être nommé à
paris donc il a fait un mouvement un peu
inverse à ce que l'on appelle la
décentralisation dramatique et le
festival son rôle principal c'est
évidemment de soutenir la création des
artistes d'essayer de faire partager au
plus grand nombre possible toutes
catégories sociales confondues
le plaisir du spectacle mais ça n'a pas
été du jouer un rôle permanent pendant
les onze mois restant de l'année sur les
quartiers d'avignon ça c'est autre chose
c'est une responsabilité de la politique
culturelle municipale avec d'autres
types d'institutions sinon il faudrait
changer
le budget du festival l'équipe du
festival les compétences du festival
donc vers des signes il faudrait
redéfinir son rôle alors ce que l'on
peut faire ce qu'on peut imaginer m'a
souvent là serait plus le festival
d'avignon et ça ne jouerai absolument
plus le même salut mignon mais réagir au
documentaire jean vilar voulait un
théâtre pour que le banquier et
l'ouvrier puis se côtoyaient force est
de constater et vous l'avez bien
démontré dans votre dans votre
documentaire que ni l'un ni l'autre
aujourd'hui ne va je crois que la
question qui est posée qui est bien
posée d'ailleurs parce par ce film c'est
qu'avignon ce qui fonctionne c'est
plutôt le off ce qui coûte c'est plutôt
le in et la question que nous devons
nous poser c'est que tout le monde
finances sous prétexte de création pour
que seulement 2% de la population ne
puisse assister au spectacle c'est
vraiment le problème qui est posé qui se
posent à avignon et toutes proportions
gardées en garde et qui se posait avec
la même acuité
lorsque je suis arrivé aux commandes de
la ville du blanc mesnil
alors par ailleurs faire montre joseph
vous montrer aussi dans votre
documentaire les bienfaits des activités
culturelles sur les jeunes aussi sur les
adultes qui ont des vies difficiles
elles apparaissent comme un refuge au
coeur de leur vie est ce que ce
documentaire aussi pourvoi était une
façon de montrer que la culture
aujourd'hui sa place dans la société
négliger un moment elle en aurait
particulièrement besoin pour répondre un
peu
monsieur faivre d'arcier sur le rôle du
festival ses moyens effectivement il est
de là qu un mois par an et en même temps
quand vous écoutez son nouveau directeur
olivier py jeu le site est dit
aujourd'hui il faut parachever cette
démocratisation culturelle et ils
parcourir les 300 mètres qui nous sépare
de la banlieue d'avignon
donc je pense que peut-être que le
festival s'interroge lui-même sur sa
finalité
peut-être qu'il a compris parce qu'il
est aussi financé on va en partie par
l'argent public qui l'a peut-être
d'autres missions à mener alors oui sur
le bienfait du théâtre en l'occurrence
prescrits il s'agit de théâtre et la
compagnie goût qu'on qu'on voit dans le
film qui s'appelle la compagnie mise en
scène c'est des amateurs mais c'est
aussi les professionnels ils sont
intéressants parce qu'il croise deux
types de financement politique de la
ville et politiques culturelles et là on
est à cheval sur une expérience un peu
unique et qui est assez remarquable
et quand on voit par exemple je me
souviens dans le film cette maman de
confession musulmane qui s'appelle linda
et qui a participé et bien à une
expérience de théâtre de théâtre
phénoménal puisqu'une ils ont été dans
le palais des papes dans le festival in
après des années de pratique amateur
mais à la frontière et qu'on la voit
répété que je la vois moi qui au tiers
sont sous foulard parce qu'il va y avoir
la représentation via le kit et ça je
crois que c'est peut-être le
professionnel de théâtre qui pourra nous
en parler mais sur scène elle revêt
d'autres habits et finalement des lieux
comme ça où on est capable de revêtir
une autre identité d'être observés et
bien non plus comme la maman de trois
enfants qui galèrent dans la vie mais
comme bas la reine puisqu'elle joue une
reine sur scène et ben y'a pas beaucoup
d'endroits qui offre sa et le théâtre
l'offre et quand vous dites il ya deux
réalités qui existent finalement bomba
et à l'art pour l'art et le soutient la
création et je pense qu'effectivement on
n'a pas forcément besoin de demander à
la création d'avoir des rôles en même
temps quand juste derrière parce qu'il
faut voir clair quand on sort des
remparts exclu physiquement là vous avez
des remparts c'est comme ça c'est la
ville est fait comme ça mais qui a plus
une affiche de théâtre plus une affiche
de théâtre des bouffes est 50 m on peut
qu'être étonné de cette réalité-là
l'interrogent elle doit je pense lui
mais là alors on revient à la question
de ce que vous disiez qu'elle est
le rôle d'un festival alors quand on
regarde votre documentaire on se pose
plusieurs questions
d'abord est-ce qu'un festival doit peut
toucher l'ensemble d'une population
ensuite est ce que la culture doit être
pensé uniquement comme facteur de lien
social
et puis sur quels critères aujourd'hui
la politique culturelle se définit on
réécoute un extrait de votre
documentaire
ces gens vivent ici c'est rompre avec
paris avec la l'idéologie parisienne
avec l'or
le velours rouge un refus du théâtre
fermé sur ses avantages ses classes
sociales sur ces tarifs est sûre revoilà
sur les dominants il faut bien dire que
les origines de villars des origines de
sinon de pauvreté en tout cas de très
très grande modestie alors on l'a
entendu on l'a dit le rêve de jean vilar
était de réunir autour du théâtre toutes
les catégories sociales
et puis il a découvert un jour que
finalement et bien il n'y avait pas tant
d'employés et d'ouvriers que ça dans son
public il était très déçu ce qui est
posée ici c'est l'idée de la
démocratisation culturelle
j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête quelques
instants sur cette question là jean
michel djian visa pas encore entendu
c'est quoi la démocratisation culturelle
d'abord c'est une grande ambition
républicaine c'est l'idée quand même que
la république a à faire à tout le monde
et que à un moment donné d'un processus
d'intervention publique toutes les
populations parce qu'elles payent des
impôts ont le droit aussi en retour
d'avoir une offre qui est de qualité
quelle qu'elle soit aussi bien quand on
construit des autoroutes que quand on
produit de l'art ou quand on aide des
institutions culturelles ça c'est le
premier point
et quand malraux on cite malraux parce
que c'est la grande figure
proche de de gaulle rappelons le c'était
quand même un personnage atypique qui
avait auprès de malraux le titre de
ministre d'état et qui avait une un
verbe tellement puissant que son verbe
pouvez remplacer son budget en gros une
vision voilà une vision et c'est très
important parce que si on revient à
l'actualité
ce qui manque c'est précisément le verbe
et la vision or le verbe et la vision
existait du temps de malraux elle a
existé pendant un certain nombre
d'années la vème république a été habité
par le verbe et par la vision du monde
par l'idéal est aussi par un facteur qui
est très important à signaler dans ce
festival où ailleurs peu importe c'est
l'idée de l'engagement du militantisme
avant sans jouer les nostalgiques il
existait des jean vilar mais bien
d'autres aussi déjà noront dans un
ministère capable parce que ces
personnes était elle même habité par une
grande idée de la démocratisation et est
capable d'investir de leur personne de
l'engagement politique dans ce domaine
là de l'art et la création et cessons
ces gens là qui ont fabriqué des
institutions se sont pas nous nous les
nous en sommes les héritiers
aujourd'hui ce sont eux qui les ont
fabriqués
et c'est démocratisation culturelle dont
on se rabat un peu les oreilles quand ma
main c'est à dire qu'on la sort quand ça
nous arrange
quand ça va pas on la refait resurgir
comme étant une plaie républicaine
or le seul souci gourna où l'ennui c'est
que j'appartiens pas mis sur la culture
de gérer ce problème
c'est à l'école ça l'éducationnationale
c'est l'éducation artistique qui est en
charge de régler ce problème de la
démocratisation du public en face l'art
et la création
catherine tasca voulait réagir oui je
voulais simplement rappelé que le grand
rêve de villars il a été
formé en avignon comme au tnp ensuite il
y à une soixante plus de 60 ans et entre
temps la société a incroyablement bouger
incroyablement changer ce que je pense
c'est que la préoccupation de
démocratisation culturelle
elle a toujours été présente et elle est
encore aujourd'hui chez les différents
acteurs de cette politique culturelle
simplement elle s'énonce différemment
parce que la société a bougé et c'est
vrai qu'il ya 60 ans on ne posait pas la
question de la cotisation en opposant au
fond les centres-villes bien dotées et
les périphéries plus ou moins reléguée
ont posé la question de la lutte des
classes il ya 60 ans c'était en termes
bien bien différent d'où les noms c'est
d'ailleurs le patron et l'ouvrier dans
le même cadre la question différente
je le répète cette ambition de la
démocratisation
c'est à dire au fond du partage avec le
plus grand nombre et bien c'est une
ambition qui reste profondément présente
dans chez tous les acteurs culturels
simplement ils l'expriment il l'a 3
traduisent différemment je pense qu'on
ferait une grave erreur en occitan en
opposant le projet artistique qui au
fond est l'épiné dorsale de touche
estivale de toute grande manifestation
culturelle et la construction du lien
social
la construction du lien social elle peut
s'appuyer sur des manifestations
artistiques et culturelles
elle n'en dépend pas elle dépend de
beaucoup d'eau tant de choses dans ma
sphère remercié réunir l'employé
l'ouvrier le notaire le banquier en fait
quand même le festival d'avignon il est
arrivé il faut pas croire ça parce que
les comités d'entreprise de même en
maintenant dans l'offre organiser des
spectacles et des programmations et les
banquiers j'en connais d'ailleurs
suffisamment pour pouvoir les sollicité
d'ailleurs au titre du mécénat pour le
festival d'avignon donc ça m'est arrivé
tout est fait et maintenant évidemment
il faut pas chercher à ce que le public
fait suer de l'avignon reflète
exactement la composition
socioprofessionnelle de la population
française
de la même manière que l'image du foot
le match de foot vous n'allez pas
trouver la composition exacte de la
société française dans un stade dans un
festival c'est quand même un événement
populaire le festival d'avignon in et
off confondues il est énorme il et il
est même parfois trop gigantesque mais
il représente vraiment quand même une
ambition qui a fonctionné qui a réussi
qui est de conduire évidemment un gros
manque de gens à toujours voir du
théâtre du spectacle vivant de la danse
et ça se passe à avignon alors vous
parlez
jean-michel gens il admis 2 de l'école
est-ce que effectivement on n'a pas
tendance à demander à la culture de
remplir aussi une mission qui incombe
aux d'abord à l'école est ce qu'il ya
une répartition des rôles qui
aujourd'hui est un peu confuse écoutez
depuis 1958 et surtout depuis l'arrivée
de jack lang
wisair la culture en 80 il ya eu des
tentatives et catherine tasca on est
d'ailleurs été pilote aussi de grands
plans sur l'éducation artistique en
essayant de lisier en permanence le
milan avec une pure m et c'est
l'éducation nationale parce qu'en
réalité si on est un peu idéal ici on a
un peu fou il faut l'être dans ce milieu
excusez moi on est trop conforme les
trop on les trous conforme espère que la
réalité économique est en retard ce qui
peut se faire on les entrées en ce
moment avec olivier poivre d'arvor à
france culture d'imaginer quelque chose
de fort avec la ligue de l'enseignement
sur l'idée précisément de se dire allez
on y va
puisque nous on a la chance à france
culture de recevoir beaucoup d'artistes
d'intellectuels proposons l'heure
d'aller dans des classes là où ils ont
été eux mêmes souvent élèves voilà
pourquoi parce qu'on s'est aperçu nous
que précisément les artistes et les
intellectuels n'ont pas ce nom les
intellectuels les artistes surtout envie
de donner de leur de leur barre de leur
personne a des enfants parce qu'ils
voient bien eux aussi sont pas fous que
l'accès des plus
défavorisés on le trouve plus les mots
maintenant bon de ceux qui n'ont pas
accès et bien cela si on va pas véreuses
marche pas donc allons vers eux c'est
tout et donc ce qui va se faire à la
rentrée est un exemple bon essai l'école
on s'est même dit l'école va pas suffire
il faut un mouvement derrière ou alors
par exemple catherine tasca je reviens
vers vous je sais que vous avez commencé
votre carrière au ministère de la
culture ces autorités de d'andré malraux
il ya eu les maisons de la culture
quel a été l'impact des maisons de la
culture considérable dans toutes les
villes où elles se sont développées
maintenant elles n'ont pas toujours
étaient éternels dans leur mission elles
aussi elles ont évolué et surtout le
contexte des villes dans lequel elles
ont fait leur leur oeuvre a
considérablement changé et moi j'ai
dirigé pendant cinq ans la maison de la
culture de grenoble et bien grenoble
après la maison de la culture au bout de
je dirais déjà d'une quinzaine d'années
de fonctionnement de la maison n'était
plus le même grenoble ça avait essaimé
parce que il ya une chose quand vous
évoquez l'école et la relation école
culture yens une chose dont on est
certain c'est que plus jeune
le contact est pris avec la culture avec
l'offre artistique mieux sceller mieux
le le jeune citoyen va être mis en
appétit
parce que tout ça c'est pas une question
de programme soit même les enseignements
fondamentaux à l'école tout ça est une
question et jay d'éveil
oui face à l'occasion à la crise les
sensibilités et de mise en appétit et
cette mise en appétit elle n'a lieu que
si le contact que ce faire et le plus
tôt est le mieux
et c'est vrai que dans son projet andré
malraux ne posez pas ça exactement dans
ces termes il était beaucoup plus sûr
j'irai presque le choc amoureux entre
love l'oeuvre et le grand public
la capacité si possible pour tous les
adultes de quelques messieurs milieu
qu'il soit d'être en effet et veiller à
ses bottés
mais ce qui est apparu plus clairement à
partir des années 80
et 2000 lorsque nous avons fait le plan
d'éducation artistique à l'école c'est
la nécessité de traiter ça très tôt dans
la vie de chaque jeune citoyen où qu'il
soit alors est ce que ça veut pas dire
finalement que ce sur quoi on pêche
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être le la façon
de donner accès à la culture sur quoi
s'interroger est-ce qu'on confond
diffusion démocratisation et création
aujourd'hui la diffusion n'a d'avenir
que que si l'ia je le répète cette mise
en appétit et donc il faut qu'il y ait
un travail de préparation des changes
entre le monde de la culture et le monde
de l'éducation dont la mise en appétit
dont par catherine tasca
ça passe par des hommes des femmes qui
sont elles mêmes
encore une fois j'insiste engagé habité
par cette idée que la page est forcément
avec un grand am et participe de la
construction de la personnalité de la
sensibilité et ça ça passe par des gens
ou simplement ça passe pas seulement par
des institutions et c'est ça qui font
peut-être remettre au centre
oui l'accès mais je parle sous votre
regard et votre votre passé de directeur
du festival
l'accès il y ait un mignon les gens ont
peu valley est une condition de
ressources bien évidemment aimé le
festival participe de deux suivants sur
izella recours voilà mais de ce que j'ai
compris en tout cas en écoutant
notamment ses comédiens amateurs ou la
metteuse en scène de la compagnie que
j'ai rencontrés qui intervient dans les
quartiers et qui est physiquement dans
les quartiers dans les tours au milieu
des gamins qui passe ils font des rodéos
avec leurs motos à côté de la salle de
boxe à côté des lauriers en fleurs ou y
à rien il ya un multiplexe mais il n'y a
pas d'offre culturelle et la mjc qui
était catherine tasca était détruite en
en 2009 donc il y avait une salle de
technologie soeur whissell c'est une
culture oui même si c'est qu'ils étaient
en plus mais neuf a été détruite a été
détruite et aujourd'hui il ya des
espaces l on peut jouer sur les statuts
mais il ya des espaces socioculturels
avec des moyens réduits alors c'est
aussi la faute peut-être de deux je
dirais de l'administration de la ville
que d'avoir fait ces choix là mais il
suffit pas de rendre disponible il faut
aussi accompagner et tous m'ont dit
qu'il s'agissait de d'une traversée que
ces gens fallait les chercher mais
simple pas simplement les mettre
regardez le roi lear comme cette année
en dans la cour du palais des papes et
de leur dire alors qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé et c'est tout ce travail là
moi j'ai compris qui manquait peut-être
un petit peu
avignon 1 ce travail d'accompagnement
tient baignant dans les meilleurs vous
êtes maire du blanc-mesnil l'accès à la
culture pour vous c'est vous comment
vous le consensus et c'est très
important mais permettez moi de dire que
je j'ai l'impression que tout est fait
dans ce pays pour que les choses soient
jugées pertinentes seulement
lorsqu'elles sont réservées a finalement
très peu de personnes
il le fait de ne pas les comprendre et
censé les rendre intelligente parfois
lorsque j'ai pris mes fonctions à la
mairie du blanc mesnil
nous avions une salle conventionnés
où on avait des troupes en résidence
qu'il allait d'ailleurs performer à
avignon très bien je respecte le travail
qui a été fait mais on m'a expliqué
qu'on ne pouvait pas ouvrir la
programmation parce que le cahier des
charges était très contraint moyennant
quoi la ville versait une subvention de
deux millions et demi
bien plus que la ville d'avignon au
festival d'avignon avec bien moins de
retomber puisque j'ai lu 23 millions
d'euros de retombées pour la ville
d'avignon chez nous c'est zéro et on
allait chercher le public au moyen de
bus à paris
la ligne recettes les les entrées
représentait 3 % seulement du budget ça
prouve bien qu'on a péché on n'a pas
touché la bonne population on n'est pas
allé aujourd'hui on a reprogrammé
la salle n'est plus conventionnés nous
avons reprogrammé le la salle qui a
changé nous qui est devenu le théâtre
neuf et hier c'est évident
aujourd'hui les salles sont pleines et
on amène à nouveau un public d'origine
ouvrière la vitre en selle samedi
c'est un public d'origine ouvrière qui
retrouve le chemin de la salle de la
salle de spectacle justement parce que
la programmation est adaptée mais alors
justement au moins s'est également voulu
adapter cette programmation comment vous
évaluez les attentes du public aux
maladies se trouve que j'ai peut-être un
avantage c'est que je suis blanc mais
lillois de naissance mes parents avant
moi donc je vis sur la ville et j'ai pas
besoin d' enquêtes d'opinion pour savoir
pour ressentir ce qui attend la
population or pendant toute la campagne
électorale est bien avant les gens nous
ont dit monsieur
changer nous la programmation on a des
gens qui habitent le blanc-mesnil depuis
plus de 50 ans qui ont trouvé pour la
première fois le chemin de la salle
c'est quand même exceptionnel mais ce
que tout votre population partage
forcément votre votre idée de ses
attentes
tout jeu serait présomptueux madame mais
force est de constater que les salles
sont pleines et que la population a
l'air satisfaite
vous êtes aller davantage vers le
divertissement pas pas seulement mais là
nous avons 1 agnès jaoui en résidence
qui a performé l'autre jour qui avait un
spectacle magnifique
nous avons fait un temps fort brassens
qui les enfants de toutes origines
sociales et culturelles chantait
brassens à tue tête sans compter les
anciens qui eux connaissaient les
paroles par coeur
nous aurons un spectacle sur nougaro
nous avons eu idir pour le nouvel an
kabyle la programmation est très
éclectique et chacun y trouve son et
dans ces cas-là vous composer une équipe
pour choisir la différentes
programmations nous avons un directeur
des affaires culturelles qui sera
d'ailleurs à avignon très rapidement qui
est quelqu'un du métier qui est acteur
et nous avons une équipe qui est bien
évidemment s'occupe de la programmation
nous préparons la rentrée et la saison
suivante et avec le même souci la même
exigence de qualité oui monsieur le
secteur associatif y a pas d'association
qui traditionnellement passé contrat
avec la vivre dans certains cas de
figure pas tous partent alors il y avait
auparavant des troupes en résidence qui
passaient des contrats avec
l'association qui gérait le forum
culturel
nous avons fait de ce théâtre un théâtre
municipal avec une direction des
affaires culturelles une civière les
choses nous aux municipalités ce théâtre
parce que tout simplement on
m'expliquait que je ne pouvais pas je
demandais une vingtaine de dates de
manière à modifier un petit peu la
programmation reste qu'elle soit adaptée
aux demandes de la population nous
sommes aussi la politique je n'apprends
rien madame tasca pour faire en sorte
que de faire en sorte que ce que la
population que nos programmations colle
avec ce que la population nous demandent
justement si le service public de la
culture consiste à répondre
aux attentes du public comment on peut
évaluer cestas et subjectif finalement
oui je pense qu'on peut pas s'en tenir à
une réponse aux attentes du public
il faut les prendre en compte et je
conçois parfaitement qu'un élu l'élu
local soit attentif à la tente à la
demande de sa population mais il ya
aussi d'autres enjeux si on parle
vraiment d'un projet artistique et
culturel
il faut dans le même temps être capable
de faire place à des manifestations je
dirais innovantes parce que ce qu'on
cherche à faire à travers le théâtre à
travers la danse ou ou à travers la la
musique ça n'est pas seulement de coller
à la tente des publics parce qu'il ya
pas un public y en a il y en a plusieurs
et de ce point de vue la diversité de la
programmation est sans doute un enjeu
important quand on est sur un territoire
populaire mais on peut pas s'en tenir à
ça il faut aussi donner l'occasion de
découvrir et de découvrir des choses qui
ne sont pas forcément à l'image de la
demande spontanée du public c'est ce qui
est difficile
ça a été difficile aussi pour jean vilar
vous savez il n'a pas toujours été en
plein accord avec son public loin loin
de là c'est à dire à la fois se donner
les moyens de
faire venir soir le maximum de gens mais
en même temps avoir un projet avoir une
proposition
bernard faivre d'arcier si on fait une
sorte de marketing culturel est ce que
c'est aux dépens de l'expérimentation
artistique fait peur à martigues
marketing l'aventuré des partitions on
se sert de han mais si on considère le
processus culturels ou artistiques dans
son ensemble il ya évidemment plusieurs
phases il ya une phase certainement de
création qui va directement intéressés
des artistes et une phase aussi de
diffusion de médiation de formation donc
il faut trouver les bons processus et je
dirais le bon échelon territorial ou le
faire alors effectivement si vous
installez un centre de création dans une
ville qui n'est qu'il n'est pas prêt à
le faire ou à le recevoir ou qui n'a pas
les moyens de le faire il va y avoir un
problème et il faudra davantage sans
doute accentué mettre l'accent sur la
diffusion ou la formation de la
médiation ou le rassemblement des
publics avignon la chose est un peu
particulière parce que comme je lis du
festival d'avignon n'est pas chargée de
l'action culturelle de la ville donc
c'était la ville de prévoir affirmant
cette action culturelle là un festival
n'est qu'un festival somme tout ceci dit
c'est un festival qui est où il ya du
monde un monde beaucoup plus varié qu'on
le croit et qui prouve quand même que il
faut faire attention raisonnement qui
voudraient assimilés minoritaires et
unitaire parce que il ya beaucoup de
pratique minoritaire la lecture est
minoritaire
on peut le dire mais le football aussi
donc enfin d'assistance et un match et
ça veut pas dire forcément à lithaire et
souvent dès qu'il s'agit de culture on
veut croire qu'il ya une association
comme sa minorité rallye terre c'est une
pratique minoritaire
ça n'intéresse que 5% ou 10% de la
population donc satellitaire bah non il
faut éviter ça d'ailleurs je regrette
que parfois les élites en question ne
s'intéressent pas davantage au théâtre
pour l'instant ils s'intéressent plus à
la gastronomie au voyage
la bourse ou à l'art contemporain mais
pas assez à mon avis au spectacle vivant
dont évitant ce genre de choses et
considérons que finalement une
démocratie c'est une succession aussi de
pratiques minoritaires et que voilà
certains seront attirés par le
patrimoine d'autres parlent à la
création
jean-michel bien la culture pour la
culture c'est salir on n'imagine pas que
guillaume gallienne ou découflé ou
montalvo son exercice très populaire et
qui les a aidées d'abord seul état c'est
pas un secteur privé
c'est eux qui ont joué notre carte qui
est la leur et qui manifestement répond
aussi à des exigences donc cette espèce
de dichotomie entre les deux ça n'existe
pas dire c'est encore une fois s'il ya
des personnes à des artistes qui ont
envie de toucher un large public
alors de là à dire qu'il faut pas du
tout financer la création
c'est un tort inimaginable imaginons que
du jour en main le secteur public
collectivités locales et a confondu
réduisent totalement ces aides à la
création que vont voir et entendre nos
enfants et nos petits enfants dans 20
ans 30 ans rien ils vont réécouter
brassens est très bien brassens à mais
ils vont qu'est-ce qu'ils vont entendre
de 9
c'est ça qu'il faut imaginer aujourd'hui
alors justement les questions
budgétaires pour son premier exercice
budgétaire le gouvernement de françois
hollande est son premier jean marc
ayrault avait essayé de diminuer les
crédits de la culture de 3,2 pour cent
jamais depuis 30 ans le budget en avait
été réduit à ce point pourquoi est ce
que c'est juste une question d'économie
non j'ai juste
angela park réponse est je pense que
l'actuel président de la république n'a
pas une vie tirée personnels majeurs
pour la culture c'est tout j'ai peur de
personne
en tout cas c'est un des paramètres et
que automatiquement vous savez c'est là
la france est une monarchie contrarié
c'est à dire qu'on a un président kita
qui étaient rois et les mises la culture
ont joué le rôle sans que ça péjoratif
du tout bas ça n'a pas toujours été dans
le théâtre des bouffes
et là il faut à un moment donné se dire
que un président qui n'a pas forcément
envie d'avoir un bouffon dans le sens
noble du terme il y aura pas de
politique culturelle
donc heureusement il ya des
professionnels il y à une majorité qui
poussent à la roue pour que précisément
on revienne à des niveaux un peu plus
plus efficace voilà mais c'est très
récent
on l'a vu on l'a vu c'est très récent il
faut remonter la pente
catherine tasca mais je pense que
personne ne peut être indifférent aux
problèmes des contraintes budgétaires
c'est vrai pour un élu local comme pour
un élu national ceci étant ma conviction
est que tout recul dans ce domaine est
vraiment un dommages portés au pays
parce que nous avons besoin de se vivre
ailleurs le premier général il a dit que
c'est une erreur il a eu raison de le
dire je pense en effet que c'était une
erreur parce que ça n'est pas là que
l'on va rétablir je dirais la santé des
finances publiques et c'est un domaine
dans lequel tout recul qui aboutit à la
fermeture d'un équipement ou à la
diminution de ses moyens de travail est
un recul pour le pays
en tout le monde parle de
démocratisation artistique et culturelle
et pour le faire il faut y mettre les
moyens
or les sommes en jeu et c'est là que je
pense qu'il ya eu une erreur politique
ne justifie pas même si on est dans une
logique d'économie c'est vrai et c'était
l'idée de l'exception culturelle aussi
c'est vrai qu'il faut traiter ce secteur
avec beaucoup de ménagement parce que
c'est quand même c'est un terreau qui
est essentiel pour la démocratie et pour
la vie culturelle
alors effectivement on l'a dit c'est ces
trente dernières années la france a
connu de grandes modifications et social
et culturel la montée en puissance des
collectivités taurian territoriale
pardon et puis l'industrie culturelle
qui arrivent au galop on réécoute un
extrait documentaire c'est un très grand
grand grand support d'activités vous
savez que
un euro est investi de la culture normal
rapporte 4 euros alors donc
et voilà vous voyez le rapport que ça
peut faire et c'est vrai que ce surplus
d'activité pendant le festival
parce que bien sûr il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de monde je crois qu'on n'est
pas loin de 181 me des dossards mines
qui sont kiki qui passent dans d'avignon
pendant le festival
alors que la population est de 85 des
habitants je pense que c'est pas mal je
pense que c'est celle où il pourrait pas
y avoir de festival avec le temps les
gens du théâtre mais aussi avec des
avignonnais c'est un tout il faut que
toute la ville se mobilise pour le t1 de
ça et les comédiens sur la après paul
houée pour faire le rôle alors dans le
documentaire on apprend que le festival
d'avignon c'est plus de 20 millions de
retombées pour la ville
un festival c'est forcément synonyme de
rentrée d'argent pour un territoire
selon la sacem un euro investi pour un
festival rapporte 3 euros au territoire
est ce que c'est toujours le cas
catherine tasca oui oui oui moi c'est
une évidence
souvenez vous de la grande grève des
intermittents en 2003 avec les festivals
à l'arrêt et bien tous les commerçants
étaient aux cent coups voir dans la dans
la rue pour réclamer que ça puisse
reprendre
bien sûr que c'est un surplus d'activité
c'est aussi un surplus de vie pour pour
une ville qui accueille un festival si
le festival s'arrête tout à coup il ya
un trou noir
juste une petite réflexion quand on
vient d'écouter ce restaurateur qui est
sur l'eau de la place du palais des
papes et qui fait partie d'ailleurs de
de la municipalité ump précédente et qui
était en charge du tourisme et qui nous
dit baffie simple finalement la culture
ça rapporte
c'est ce qui est en train de me dire et
puis les comédiens finalement sont là
pour jouer leur rôle et puis nous pour
jouer le nôtre finalement ça suffit pas
tellement débat pas de questions on
prend ça on dit bah oui finalement mais
quand on pose la question de l'utilité
alors j'entends tout ce qui a été dit
sur place
ici dans le débat quand on pose la
question de l'utilité dans un
le contexte budgétaire restreint et bien
tout de suite là on outils mais
attention la culture doit être forcément
juin au lac y voilà et je pense que
c'est nécessaire quand même de
s'interroger sur le rôle de ce festival
bien sûr ce n'est pas sa fonction
avignon et m'en sortir de cet exemple
précis de s'occuper de la vie de les
onze mois 12 mois de l'année mais en
même temps il a probablement rôle à
jouer alors il ya un motif d'inquiétude
des collectivités c'est la suppression
des dotations publiques 11 milliards sur
trois ans - 3 vient à venir cette année
qui va trinquer
bernard faivre d'arcier c'est les petits
festivals sous perfusion publique qu'est
ce quelle conséquence sur les grands
événements dont il ya des conséquences
au niveau 8 aimant des collectivités
locales qui estiment ne plus avoir de
moyens financiers suffisants ils doivent
faire effectivement des arbitrages et
parfois elles n'orbitent par va vers la
culture mais d'autres dépenses la ville
davy dans d'ailleurs a réduit un peu
cette subvention au festival d'avignon
l'histoire du festival d'avignon à
l'origine c'était une régie municipale
et ensuite l'état n'a cessé d'augmenter
sa contribution quand si bien que
maintenant ce festival l'acquis
rapportant à la ville il est
principalement financé par l'état
il faut pas l'oublier c'est normal
d'ailleurs parce que c'est une opération
d'intérêt national et la ville justement
qui a réduit proportionnellement
beaucoup de ces financements dorée de
redéployer son budget à l'égard de des
activités culturelles éducatives socio
culturelle des quartiers
c'est vraiment ça qu'il faut faire parce
que c'est pas le festival c'est pas la
petite équipe du festival qui va s'en
occuper
donc les collectivités locales
maintenant sont conduites à faire des
choix
évidemment dans l'histoire du budget on
s'aperçut que de plus en plus les
collectivités locales avaient des
multiculturelle qui maintenant
représente une somme globale bien
supérieure à celle de l'état donc la
responsabiliser et à c'est maintenant
entre les mains des collectivités
locales
alors elle effectivement d'agir elles
sont pas obligés de faire des choix
préjudiciable la culture sa raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs la bise la culture
actuellement essaye fleur pellerin
d'établir des pactes culturel du comité
local pour éviter
cet effet de retour en arrière alors on
avance dans le débat il reste trois
minutes quelle solution à la baisse des
subventions l augmentation des coûts
plus de mécénat on parle de plus en plus
du crowdfunding pour financer est ce que
ce sont des modèles qui vont se
développer s'intensifier bon moi je
pense que des modèles qui s'invente
encore aujourd'hui récemment j'étais
avec mes amis bretons en train découvrir
qu'un festival qui était qui était mort
il ya trois quatre ans rené cette année
alors que d'autres sont tout simplement
supprimée pour les raisons évoquées mais
tout simplement parce que je parle de
bobital un festival de rock band tout
simplement ils ont joué notre carte
celle de faire appel à des systèmes de
d'économie partager stx qui ce bang bang
ou d'autres il ya vraiment des modèles
économiques très étonnant qu'ils ne font
que répondre un modèle déjà très
diversifié les vieilles charrues le
festival rock vers le premier grand
festival en france ce sont que des
bénévoles
vous avez le au festival de la rochelle
ou à bourges sont pas des bénévoles ce
sont des professionnels donc des
économies très différente dans les
festivals et puis dans la culture
vous avez le spectacle fusion qui coûte
cher et on le sait et on sait pourquoi
mais vous avez aussi l'art contemporain
vous avez le cinéma la musique et tout
ça il ya une économie
je veux dire qu'il s'auto j'ai en même
temps il ya des profits à faire donc on
est dans une économie extrêmement éclaté
c'est pour ça qu'il faut se mettre en
garde ne pas résumer la culture à une
économie assistée c'est pas du tout le
cas
tiens meilleur moyen des modèles comme à
moi je crois que la culture c'est pas
selon spectacle vivant vous avez
parfaitement raison de le dire ce que
nous avons essayé de faire c'est de
d'aller vers la population par exemple
en programmant un spectacle de théâtre
au parc urbain sont pas très chers de la
ville
nous avons programmé au pied des cités
des concerts de musique classique dire
que le budget consacré et est utilisé de
manière à ce que ceux qui payent
puissent bénéficier un peu plus
qu'auparavant
des spectacles et je pense que c'est la
bonne direction et on peut aller vers la
population en restant exigeant en europe
est accessible et être ambitieux 4
tasca et on arrive à terme du débat moi
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de modèle
exclusif et que ça serait une erreur de
penser qu'il faut être dans le tout mais
senna ou recherche de deux fonds ou dans
le tout public
ceci étant personnellement je pense
qu'il est essentiel que subsiste un
secteur public de la culture qui peut
parfaitement cohabiter avec d'autres
formes d'autres économies d'autres
modèles mais qui est indispensable pour
ce que nous avons essayé de lire c'est à
dire le soutien à la création
le soutien à l'invention le soutien aux
jeunes talents ceux qui ne sont pas
installés sur le marché encore et donc
ce qui est essentiel
oui développons d'autres ressources mais
maintenant la violeur d'un secteur
public pour préserver l'exception
culturelle française merci à tous d'être
venus sur ce plateau merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis je vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour la dernière
émission de l'année nous parlerons des
monnaies locales à la semaine prochaine
sur public sénat